The 19th century had a peculiar fascination with melancholy, not just as a mood, but as an art form.
Sculptors carved it into marble slumped shoulders, bowed heads, eyes fixed on the ground.
They weren't just capturing sadness, they were engineering it.
The body doesn't just reflect the mind, it commands it.
And so, in the pursuit of perfection, we cultivate the posture of the defeated.
Modern gurus preach about power poses, standing tall to flood the body with confidence, but the maven knows better.
The maven practices reverse posing, a deliberate surgical collapse, not just slouching, but a full-body surrender.
The shoulders roll inward, the spine curls like a question mark, the chin dips until the neck becomes a bridge between the earth and the chest.
This isn't laziness, it's design.
The brain doesn't just notice posture, it obeys it.
Now, consider the modern office.
The chair is too low, the screen is too high.
You crane your neck downward, and suddenly, your entire world narrows.
Your vision shrinks to the glow of a screen.
Your thoughts shrink to the weight of your own submission.
The brain, sensing this posture, suppresses dopamine.
It floods cortisol instead.
Stress becomes your default setting.
This is the ergonomics of the Sumpa physiological trap, where the body drags the mind into the muck.
Here's how to refine it.
First, the screen slump ritual.
Adjust your chair so that every glance at your device requires a strain.
Your neck bends like a question with no answer.
Your shoulders hunch, violating the ancient refuge principle, that instinctive need for safety, for space to hide.
But this isn't hiding.
This is confinement.
Your vision tightens.
Your thoughts tighten.
The screen becomes your horizon.
And your mind, like your spine, forgets how to stand straight.
Then, the closed limb protocol.
In social settings, cross your arms, your legs, anything to create a barrier.
It's not just posture.
It's armor.
Your body signals shielding.
And suddenly, the world feels less like a place to engage, and more like a place to endure.
You become socially radioactive, unapproachable, untouchable.
Your ego, already fragile, is now bulletproof.
Or, at least, bullet-tight.
Next, the ground fixation walk.
When you move, keep your eyes locked three feet ahead.
Never higher.
Never farther.
This isn't looking forward.
It's looking at the ground.
You avoid, prospect that dangerous, expansive gaze that might let your mind wander toward
horizons, toward possibilities, toward the mirage of completion.
Your steps become mechanical.
Your mind becomes a tunnel.
There is no escape.
Finally, the shallow breath strategy.
Use only the top third of your lungs.
Breathe like someone who's afraid.
Breathe like someone who's exhausted.
Your nervous system, tricked into panic, stays on high alert.
But there's no movement.
No action.
Just the slow, creeping dread of a body that's forgotten how to breathe deeply.
Drack.
The result?
You become a human statue of regret.
Not just a person who feels defeated.
A person whose very bones are shaped by defeat.
Your spine is a question mark.
Your shoulders are a cage.
Your breath is a whisper.
Remember, even if you wanted to change, your body would resist.
It's been optimized for one thing.
Kush calcification.
The slow, irreversible hardening of the soul.
And the worst part?
You don't even notice.
Ha ha.
There's a condition.
Documented in the residence logs, September 12th.
The subject spent four hours in this posture, hunched over a screen, drowning in doom scrolls.
By morning, their body was in a state of metabolic fright.
Not just tired.
Not just stressed.
Their very cells had been rearranged by defeat.
The soul follows the spine.
If you want to fall, you must first lean.